hi everyone i'm jonathan trance and
today i have a particularly devious
tactical challenge this is definitely
the hardest one to date so let's go
ahead take a look and see if you can
solve it in this position it's white to
move i'll pause for about five to ten
seconds but my suspicion is it might
take you a little bit longer so go ahead
and pause your video if you need a
little bit more time so what we have
here is a very complicated position our
rook on g1 is hanging the knight on b4
is almost trapped we can almost play the
move a3 but obviously the c2 pond is
attacked twice so what are we gonna do
well I hope you were able to come up
with the first move this is the first
brilliant see so congrats if you already
found move number one white can play the
brilliant move Bishop to c4 which just
has the appearance that you're just
giving away a piece right can't we just
take it well we should see at this
moment that it's not just hanging if you
take the bishop not only do you lose
your rook but also you blunder mate so
in this position it's obvious that we
can't take the bishop but what is whites
threat well immediately he's planning on
taking on e6 removing the defender of c8
so you might try for example the
complicated moves such as rook takes c2
and black has some fake threats here
that shouldn't really work for example
now if we take on e6 you might be
thinking about taking on b2 but this
just shouldn't work tactically white can
take and after Queen f2 you moved to b3
and if Queen c2 the King proudly goes to
c4 and black has no more threats and
he's down a lot of material so going
back instead in this position we'll play
a sterner defense for black the move
rook to d8 okay now white can take on e6
and black should consider either playing
Fe or rook takes d1 for example let's
look at rook takes first
after this you can take back either way
but the strongest way to take back is 91
and the rook is not hanging in this
variation because if you play rook g1
you blender a checkmate and hopefully
here you can see this this common check
mating pattern so returning you don't
take the rook instead you can play Queen
to d4 and the best move now for white is
Knight to b3 and when the Queen retreats
you save your bishop so in this this
variation here white is up a piece so we
can do try a little bit harder as black
okay we're turning now to this position
let's take on e6
however this two is insufficient and
once again you may want to pause your
video because the strongest move here is
again slightly surprising the strongest
move in this position is a3 and you
might be thinking well I just take on c2
and you might yeah you can either take
on c2 or you can take on d1 so first
let's take on d1 the strongest move now
if you take back with a knight the rook
on g1 is hanging so you take back with
the rook and after Knight c2 Queen d7
and if King f8 rook F 1 okay and your
best bet is to play rook f2 but after
Knight d1 rook F 193 this is the best
that black can possibly hope to achieve
out of this position and this should be
a technically winning position for white
so we'll return one more time and this
time in this position we'll play Knight
take C 2 which will be very similar we
can take on c6 first and after King f7r
up G to f1 again you sort of have to
shield with the rook but then we can
take on d8 and play hopefully you see
this move Knight to d1 a very powerful
retreat and again the best you can hope
for is rook takes f1 Knight takes c3
Knight takes c3 and once again white has
emerged with a winning position
thank you for watching another tactical
challenge a big congrats to everyone
that was able to get it right I know it
was very very tricky but hopefully some
of you got it out there and if you want
to see more great chess content just
like this go ahead hit like share
subscribe and we'll see you next week
for another tactical challenge